Oh guys Gregory Alba here I was on
Collider comm I was coming across an
article about a movie a Russian
superhero movie called guardians and
this really treat me like Russian movie
superhero film I read a little bit about
it about a team of metahuman superheroes
whatever that were formed I think from
experiments during the Cold War that's
about as far as I know I will really
want to see the trailer though
I must break you they were born as
ordinary people
in a country that had never known
superheroes but one day they made a
choice
where the choice was made for that
okay
they were created and sworn to protect
their country the people would never
know they existed whoa Wow and when the
Soviet Union fell they remained behind
in hiding
interesting
but now evil is rising from the shadows
of the past and they must prepare the
final battle Oh God
they are our last hope
she's she's gorgeous
Soviet Union superheroes what the hell
that's cool
I have two weeks to search all of the
former Soviet Union for the superhumans
that can stop a super villain exactly
right
these people are our only hope
what's the name Dorian I would have just
preferred the actual we're all the same
Blair comes zero did this to you come
with us man bear army turned out to be
useless against the opposition forces
all attempts to stop it ended up with a
complete shutdown of any machinery whoa
like bane
so [ __ ] is that
who
damn
I've been waiting for this for half a
century there's no coming back for all
of us our experimental laboratory
designed special gear to increase your
performance nice Oh oh wow that looks
pretty cool I don't think it's based on
any specific source material it seems
like very much inspired by modern-day
superheroes meaning it like the
Fantastic Four vibe maybe a lot of more
vibes than just that yeah like all
around from all these other comic books
all these different sources and it seems
like they really made it their own I
hope that when they release it here they
allow you to watch it in its actual
language and not in this horrible
dubbing I would prefer just to watch the
subtitled version based off the trailers
it seems like they're trying to make us
like a very much American trailer of
this Russian film it's about these these
beings that were created during the Cold
War and then the end of the Soviet Union
they went it's hiding and you know the
supervillain coming out now so now that
our reading call together to fight the
evil I feel like this might have more to
give in terms of like political backdrop
and having these characters represent
something and the political parties
maybe of the like the USSR the visuals
and [ __ ] look cool the action looks
[ __ ] sweet the superpowers look bomb
diggity
you got the superheroes here with like
the manipulation abilities you got the
martial artists to do with the blades
you got the guy the bear man the wild
bear character you got the female badass
chick you know every any female badass
has to do like a scissor scissoring
around their legs move around a guy to
take them down it's like a requirement
for any badass female super this feels
like it could be something very dark
very edgy have a lot more political
statements and messages
than other superhero films we've seen
what I like to that I feel like American
audiences can get on board for is that
in so much American cinema and TV shows
Russians are like portrayed as horrible
people most of the time it's all about
the Russian mob or you go in after the
Russian mafia no I feel like Russians
kind of get a bad rep in American cinema
and I feel like this is this is cool
they're doing something cuz you know
America is like we really have the
superhero movies over here the
constantly breaking huge box office
numbers hey this is a cool chance to
check out a foreign film the film from
Russia it looks like it's an American
film inspire because of the complicated
on American film but you know at least
American comic book heroes but there's
kind of like a an apocalyptic you know
almost like you know those great video
games with awesome storytelling and
awesome designs of like a world falling
apart because it seems like that these
characters are a lot darker and it won't
be as fun but still like epic and
engaging and I really want to see this
is this looks like it's gonna be a
really cool film you got the villain who
kind of reminds you to Krang from the
Turtles
and Bane from the comics I mean I feel
inspiration but I also feel that there's
gonna be a lot of originality here as
opposed to just purely inspiration so I
know my words are a little bit all over
the place but yeah in terms of just
visuals looks bomb tone I like it I
really hope that it's not I really hope
that they give us a Russian English
subtitled version I really feel that
it's probably gonna have a lot more to
offer than just spectacle I feel like
the spectacle of it will really aid in
the storytelling as opposed to when are
we gonna get to the spectrum yeah guys
links in the description box if you want
to watch that trailer and full screen if
you're new the channel subscribe today
become rejected and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and I
want to give a shout out to Brian Penn
Toya he constantly gives long detailed
comments such as great video great vid
great job great and
and the number 8 great mate very good
feedback